what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar to discuss the final
chapter of attack on titan the day has
finally come
and there is so much to say about this
controversial ending so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
videos like this one and want to keep
them coming the best thing you could do
is smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future videos
and we will definitely be making more
attack on titan videos while you wait
for the next videos to drop feel free to
check out our colossal attack on titan
playlist which includes videos about all
titan shifters ackerman's and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
the chapter
starts as we guessed with aaron's side
of things a lot of predictions came true
and even though the very interesting
time loop theory didn't materialize
other theories we talked about on this
channel did manifest
and we'll get into all of that i just
want to say i don't think anybody should
be too surprised by this
ending but i am getting ahead of myself
so kid armit and aaron are talking in
what appears to be
the world of paths after all we did see
aaron in his
child form in this world many times here
aaron has transported them back to their
childhoods for this conversation
with their familiar hometown
surroundings we get right into it with
armin saying
he understands aaron had to do it
because he saw the future but why did he
beat him up so bad
he's referring to the scene where he
told mikasa he always hated her
and beat up armin i mentioned that this
could not have been aaron's true
feelings at the time
and here nobody should be surprised that
aaron is admitting they weren't
aaron was trying to push them all away
and he got carried away in the world of
events
aaron reveals that he wasn't a cold
calculating mastermind about it
but that he was wondering what he was
doing all the while
we're told this is the last chapter and
it's called moving towards that tree on
the hill
more on the title later armin suggests
that aaron should have this conversation
with mikasa and he agrees
while they continue their bro talk and
here armin lays it all out
what we've been talking about forever
the lelouch plan
aaron pushed them away so that he could
set them up
as heroes that saved humanity from
destruction he became the big bad guy
the devil of the earth so that his
friends could stop him and the world
would stop viewing all aldians on the
island as their enemies
lelouch from code geass did a similar
thing but aaron definitely took
a way more extreme approach where he
wiped out 80 percent of humanity
aaron didn't just plan for people to
unite against him though by wiping out
80
of humanity he also ensured that the
rest of humanity couldn't take revenge
on the island even if they wanted to
anytime soon
remember he never said he wanted what's
best for the majority or for the entire
world aaron always prioritized his
friends
and the inhabitants of the island which
is what made this plan more preferable
in his eyes
than his people waiting to be wiped out
as carl fritz intended or being wiped
out more gradually through zeke's
euthanization plan
and his plan does give the remaining
island aldians the best chance for long
happy lives which was his main goal
armin though is shocked to hear that 80
percent of humanity will be wiped out
which is understandable he wonders if
aaron really had to go that far
and asks if it was all for their sake
aaron clearly is not worried about
justifying himself and invites armin to
come with him
as he leads him to see lava aka the
liquid fire they dreamed about seeing
i really like this part it's good for
closure that these two can talk and even
see the places they dreamed of seeing
together before aaron has to go
however armin does seem to drop the
subject of whether erasing 80 percent of
the population was necessary
very quickly perhaps he knows that
there's no point to argue with aaron
here
and he might even fear that it would cut
this final conversation
short but since armin was willing to
attack and even kill
aldian comrades who viewed him as a
friend in order to help save the world
that wanted the aldians dead
i expected more resistance on this point
i gotta admit
i personally have trouble understanding
armin's character but the point is here
he continues to follow aaron's lead
as he talks about emir two thousand
years ago
emir continued to submit to king fritz
leading to the titan powers that they
still see today
even after getting the god-like power of
the titans she continued to submit to an
enemy that burned down her home
killed her father and tore out her
tongue not to mention
had her hunted down with arrows until
she stumbled upon the titan power
aaron says she submitted to him because
she was in love with him
that might just be the craziest twist in
this chapter she was not a slave to fear
but a slave to love and that love led
her to follow his commands
even though it is surprising it's not
impossible it wouldn't be the first time
someone fell in love with a cruel human
and spending time together and having
kids that they jointly raised together
probably helped her develop feelings for
her past enemy
it's also probable that fritz wasn't
always as cruel to her throughout their
marriage as he was initially so emir has
been
slaving away in the world of paths not
because she internalized a slave
mentality as i predicted but because she
loved king fritz and wanted to carry out
his wish which was to ensure that their
people will survive and multiply with
the help of titan powers
despite this aaron could feel that emir
was in pain and wish for freedom she no
longer wanted to be a slave to her love
she no longer wanted to keep submitting
to the king's will
she waited for 2 000 years hoping that
someone would free her from the pain
of her love and aaron tells us that
person was not him
but mikasa now we did see emir smiling
when mikasa killed aaron
so now we have a better sense of why she
did mikasa arguably proved that you can
love someone
without being a slave to that love by
killing the person that she did in fact
love
someone she actually wanted to protect
all her life ironically though
mikasa's actions did more or less go
according to aaron's plan
even if the plan involved killing him
but it is possible that from this
emir realized that even though she loved
fritz she didn't have to continue being
his slave
and obeying his orders she could love
him and resist his wishes
at the same time although at this point
it should be noted aaron doesn't know
yet what exactly it is that mikasa will
do which will free
amir from the pain of her love aaron
says and i quote the only thing i knew
for sure
was the result of mikasa's choice all of
it was to arrive at that result that's
why i moved forward it ironically seems
like
aaron the guy always talking about the
importance of freedom wasn't that
free he tells armin that his thoughts
have become messed up and the founder's
power has made it so there's no past or
future
it all exists at once and as a result he
had to do what he did
keywords had to this suggests that we
aren't just dealing with aaron's free
will here
he said that when the smiling titan was
approaching bertolt bertholdt wasn't
supposed to die
so he let it go and implies he led it
towards his mother
in my view this shouldn't necessarily be
read as aaron of his own free will
getting his mother killed it's as if
after merging with the founding titan
he's become this godlike being that must
ensure an inevitable result
the result that leads to the end of the
path he's on
this moment though as with many moments
in this chapter is open for
interpretation though
so let me know how you read it in the
comments finally we get
to that moment of truth and armin asks
what aaron thinks about mikasa armin
punches aaron one more time for what he
said to her
it's funny how much stronger the
reaction is here compared to the
reaction when he heard
80 percent of humanity could be wiped
out he clearly seems to get more
emotional over his friends
and yet would kill certain friends in
order to try to save the rest of
humanity
as he and connie did when they were
trying to escape from parody island
humans are full of contradictions i get
that but again armin seems
too contradictory to the point where i
can't quite wrap my head around his
character there is such a bro talk here
though
we got armin suggesting that mikasa
should forget about aaron after his
awful behavior and find someone else
and aaron says surprisingly no he
wouldn't want that
and i'm glad here we clearly get aaron
reveal his love for mikasa
where he says he wants her to only have
feelings for him
even after he dies he wants her to hold
him
in her heart for a long time and i
enjoyed this because we needed to see
this side of aaron he was so closed off
from everyone
including us during the final season
that it's refreshing to see him open up
like this
most of us knew that when he asked
mikasa in the flashback what he meant to
her
he was fishing for a more romantic
answer than family
and now it's confirmed as someone who
shipped these two from day one
i am happy with this result and this may
seem different to how aaron usually acts
but keep in mind here he's just
confiding to his best friend
i mean i've definitely had bro talks
like this growing up and yeah you say
some embarrassing stuff sometimes
you would never say to anyone else this
just proves to me that aaron is human
like the rest of us even if armin tells
him
that he didn't know aaron could say
something so awkward so blatantly
obviously this is because it's just a
bro talk and he tells armin
not to say anything about this to mikasa
because he does want her to be happy but
he also can't deny there's a part of him
that would hate to imagine her with
anyone else just like in all of us aaron
has conflicting desires
he also admits that he doesn't want to
die and that he wants to be with mikasa
and all of them
sure this talk makes him seem less
badass and he definitely doesn't come
off as cool as lelouch did during the
finale of code geass
but i think this is realistic and
refreshing after he's been closed off
for so long
armin still wants to save his friend
despite all the death and destruction
he has and will cause armin asks him if
there's
another way but aaron says there isn't
he's killed a bunch of people who didn't
want to die
and he won't be forgiven for this then
aaron says
even if he wasn't aware how this would
end with them stopping him he still
would have reduced everything
in this world to dust he wanted to turn
the earth into this brand new land
he wanted to do this at any cost clearly
these aren't the words of a free man in
my view
but more so seems like it may be the
will to keep moving forward in the
attack titan
no matter what or something like that
otherwise it wouldn't really make sense
for a human to decide to flag the earth
at all costs
even though he doesn't know why aaron
doesn't seem free to choose his own path
here
just like when he sent the smiling titan
to his mother we get the panel that was
originally supposed to be the final one
and it's grisha who was holding aaron
saying to him he's free
and i gotta admit since it was gonna be
the final panel and all i thought that
the you are free moment
would be more meaningful but i suppose
isayama didn't want to be overly
optimistic with the finale even if
grisha said it
aaron was not free in many ways as we've
seen he spoke of having to follow a path
to an inevitable destiny
he spoke of having to level the world
and leave every surface a blank
plane without knowing why he had to deal
with titans and the hatred of the world
that wanted to kill his people
rather than being a satisfying you are
free moment
that's hopeful about the next generation
as many of us expected it to be
it comes off as a deeply ironic
statement aaron goes on to explain that
he'll erase armin's memories
and the next time they meet they'll be
trying to kill each other but he says
that armin will remember this
conversation again when it all
ends and armin thanks aaron for turning
himself into a mass murderer for their
sakes
armin promises not to let this error go
to waste
and aaron says that he knows that armin
will be able to go beyond the walls
and he tells armin that he's the one who
will save humanity
it's interesting that even though armin
is against violence for the most part
he still accepts his friend and the fact
that he will wipe out 80 percent of the
population
and it must feel pretty good for aaron
to know after so much loneliness in
carrying the burden on his
own for so long that his friends still
accepted and loved him
we then jump back to the present and
armin has just regained those memories
and as i predicted titan powers have
ceased to exist
without the centipede creature i will
say that this ending does feel rushed
and one of the things that i find
weird is that the creature just
disappeared off screen without an
explanation
we are to believe that without aaron the
current founder body
the creature cannot go on living but it
isn't clear why since this creature did
live on its own
before joining with amir it is also
possible that emir
having seen what mikasa did decided to
put a stop to the world of the paths
and that ended the centipede creature as
well but it's not a super satisfying
conclusion to this final battle
since we are left to connect too many
dots by ourselves in this chapter or at
least that's my view armin sees mikasa
approaching with the air and head and
together they hug
it and armin cries mikasa asks armin if
his memories have returned too
which presents another weird unanswered
moment as an ackerman i assumed that her
memories wouldn't be able to be
suppressed or altered by
aaron after all we were told that the
145th king couldn't erase the memories
of the ackerman clan
or the asian clan and mika says from
both so i'm honestly
not sure what happened here let me know
if i'm missing something or if you guys
have an explanation for this i also am
not satisfied with the knowledge we have
of the ackermans
i wanted more if the headaches weren't
mikasa's true self resisting her
ackermann instincts what were they about
we know that aaron was lying and that
even zeke told him because i was not a
slave to her ackerman jeans
so i would have liked some other
significance to be attributed to the
headaches but moving on armin reaffirms
that mikasa's choice
probably to finish iron off wiped out
the power
of the titans from this world again this
wasn't a surprise to me i completely
expected titan paris to cease to exist
and for amir's curse to be lifted too
i definitely expected gabby and falco to
get their happyish ending
and it makes sense that reiner the plot
armored titan
is still around after wanting and even
trying to die for so long
i totally expected islama to leave this
guy who was always chasing death alive
then it turns out that aaron spoke with
jon reiner
connie and even annie they all seem to
have a positive view of him
in the end and cry for him annie even
calls him a reckless
idiot saying they never asked for his
help it goes to show that even though
they were fighting against him a little
while ago they get where he's coming
from and appreciate what he did for them
it goes to reaffirm the message of the
story that there is no clearly right or
clearly wrong
side what aaron did was clearly messed
up but can anyone say that the 145th
king's decision
for his people to die without fighting
wasn't messed up the thing is all of
their plans have flaws and they know
that which is why they can forgive aaron
despite how insane his actions were
we finally get the moment where annie
and her father hug
a moment which was interrupted by them
turning into titans in the last chapter
i'm glad she got that moment after so
long and i'm still
hoping that she ends up with armin levi
says goodbye to the survey corps
and i feel like this moment represents
these guys being freed from the world of
the paths for good
since while emir and the centipede
creature were alive no subject of emir
truly died
since they could be recalled again as we
saw with grisha tom and the others
when they came back to help during the
final titan battle
levi tells them that this is how it ends
the goal they dedicated their hearts to
and it's a nice moment this isn't a
perfect ending for the eldians but they
manage to free themselves from the curse
of the titans
and the chance of their survival is
higher than ever now
so it's really not a bad situation for
the remaining aliens compared to how it
could have been
just as he said he would aaron really
did help the island of parody and its
people
connie and jean also see sasha smiling
too
and you gotta love that smile these
moments do give us a nice sense of
closure for these characters we've lost
over the course of the story
i really do enjoy the extreme hug that
gabby and falco partake in
reiner's mother is glad he doesn't have
the power of the armored titan anymore
and hugs him saying she just needs him
by her side
it's a happy ending for her because not
only does she survive with her son
but he no longer has to worry about
amir's curse
so she no longer has to feel quite as
horrible
about trading her son's life in order to
become an honorary marlene
and she has a second chance to make
things right too which must mean the
world for her
and on the topic of atoning or making
things right for people like reiner and
annie and so on
i don't really think isayama would make
the argument they completely atoned for
their actions
and i don't think that's the point they
all participated in wars and killed many
people
all they can do now is carry that burden
and try to do the best they can moving
forward
clearly isayama is not interested in
giving us a non-problematic feel-good
ending here
mikasa takes aaron's head to bury it
where aaron always dozed off
to that tree on the hill where the story
began and then we get the allied
soldiers pointing rifles at the aldians
who were tightened just a minute ago
after all that talk about overcoming
their differences in a peaceful world if
they escaped aaron's wrath
you still have these guys pointing guns
showing that it's not that simple
and honestly i appreciate the fact that
there wasn't just complete
unquestioned world peace after aaron's
attack because that would be unrealistic
as pixus and aaron talked about as long
as there is more than one human alive
there will be conflict there would be
internal conflict even if aaron did wipe
out everyone beyond the island
we've already seen that over the course
of the story but back to this
conversation and mueller
is asking them to prove they're not
titans and the obvious question is
how but he's afraid and not thinking
clearly since these people before them
were just man-eating titans seconds ago
it's explained to them that aaron is
dead
and the power of the titans vanished now
they are just
people like anyone else this isn't too
convincing and it looks like these guys
are about to go to war again
but armin steps in the hero of humanity
he points out that even though guns are
pointed at them they're powerless and
not transforming so clearly they're
humans
finally mueller calms down a bit and
that armin takes credit for killing
aaron which is nice because i'm sure
mikasa
wouldn't want the spotlight did they
succumb to the talk no jutsu too soon
maybe but after all that will never make
the same mistake again talk
while aaron was attacking i find this
easier to believe especially since they
can't argue with the fact that aaron is
gone
and there are no titans in sight we then
get a three year timeskip of not a
perfect world but a more hopeful world
for the aldians
historia has a smile on her face as she
lives with her daughter and the farmer
i'm glad to see that even though her
hand was forced to have a kid
sooner she did find happiness in the
marriage and family
the rest of the world is not necessarily
doing as great as historia
as we're told those who survived are
tormented by their unhealing scars
even those who weren't physically
injured must have been traumatized when
they witnessed the rumbling first
hand what doesn't help them relax is the
fact that eldea has continued to build
their army under the jaegers
the island fears retaliation and they
keep cheering aaron's words
if we win we live if we lose we die if
you don't fight we can't win
fight fight end quote is this a perfect
concluding scenario
not really but that's kind of the point
even though it's not good that they
still carry fear and view the others as
potential enemies
it's good that they are working on their
military that was always the plan and it
will hopefully keep them safe when the
rest of the world has recovered could it
turn out badly if they waged war against
the rest of the world
yes but that's not guaranteed to happen
especially when you consider his story
as the queen
and our main characters have become the
allied nations
ambassadors for peace i enjoyed their
conversation
as they're heading to parody island how
reiner is still madly in love with
historia
how reiner tells jean that his picture
will be
in a field guide to horses rather than
in the history books
and i find it hilarious when jean says
it's a shame that reiner got a new lease
on life
reiner the guy who kept searching for
death has made it through that hell
it's not heaven now but the fact that
they can go back to the island after
destroying the walls betraying the
island
and killing aaron the island's hero
shows that this is a way more hopeful
future than the previous reality as
connie points out historia also
protected jon's family and connie's mom
so she'll be able to protect them too
and armin says the obvious here
conflict will never vanish i already
mentioned that in this video
we gotta accept that and look at this
end in relation to the situation before
rather than in relation to total peace
and armin feels like sharing their story
how they got over their past will help
others become better and perhaps more
peaceful as well
that's the power of stories and i feel
like attack attite itself is a story
that can make people more tolerant and
empathetic
towards the other and i believe that we
should trust in the power of stories to
make the world a better place
even if we'll never be a perfect world i
gotta admit it is random seeing gabby
and falco with levi but i guess it's
another hopeful message about how we
don't have to let our past
conflict determine our future lastly we
get the final scene mikasa is at aaron's
grave
beneath the tree on the hill she's sad
and would like to meet aaron again
just then a bird tightens her scarf
around her and she says as if to the
bird
thank you for wrapping this scarf around
me aaron and that is it
the end of attack on titan now this
ending is open to interpretation
whether the bird just reminded her of
aaron or whether the bird is straight up
a reincarnation of aaron and since he's
been freed from the world of the paths
he was able to reincarnate as the freest
of animals that never have to worry
about walls
after his death he is finally free and
he did tell mikasa he'd always be there
to wrap that scarf around her
so that's another reason to believe it's
aaron or at least a manifestation of his
will in the physical world
i know reincarnation may be out there
for some people but it is much more
common in japan to have it in stories
than here
as we saw with demon slayer again i feel
like it's open-ended enough to satisfy
whatever interpretation you want to roll
with and this part
i don't have an issue with i think it's
a nice symbolic ending
and the constant focus on bird imagery
throughout the story
takes on new significance so overall
what did i think of the last chapter of
attack on titan
it didn't surprise me for the most part
which is unusual for attack on titan
since it's blown my mind
so many times before i think endings are
really hard especially with successful
stories like this
so i think we should keep that in mind
as we judge the story
no matter what ending isayama chose some
people would have had problems with it
that's
100 the case this ending didn't blow me
away
but i don't think it was bad it
definitely didn't ruin the story for me
and i think the message of the story was
respected here
there's no easy solutions peace will
always be a work in progress
and all we can do is try to learn from
our past mistakes
and be better moving forward as i said i
did feel the ending was rushed i wish
some stuff was explained better
like the death of the centipede creature
the nature of the acronyms and their
headaches
to what extent was aaron free or not why
aaron was able to erase mikasa's
memories and so on
nevertheless i did like the ships i
liked the titan curse being lifted as i
expected it to be lifted
and i did like aaron's own spin on the
zero requiem
for the aldian people it is undoubtedly
a better
more hopeful reality than it was before
and that was aaron's goal in the first
place
let me know your thoughts did you love
it did you hate it
either way explain what you liked or
hated about it i would also love to know
if you think aaron's decision was an
error and if you preferred any other
solution to the problems that the
aldians faced
i would like to thank isayama for his
hard work and for almost
12 years of attack on titan i am very
grateful to him and his hard work
and for all of you who shared the attack
on time experience with me here on the
channel
attack on titan was especially
significant for this youtube channel
because
it was the main series that allowed us
to initially become full-time youtubers
and for that i'll always be grateful if
you did enjoy this review and want to
see more videos like it
make sure to war hammer smash that like
button if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell
we've made plenty of attack on time
videos and we'll definitely make more
especially since the anime isn't even
done yet and while you wait for the next
video to drop
feel free to check out our colossal
attack on titan playlist that includes
videos about the titan shifters and
their powers
the acronyms and their powers the times
rank for weak is the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad on patreon and here on
youtube who help make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord tuio himself alpha
sigma red-haired raven
and javier rojas and are the ones your
patrons the ones who stay on top
all clans ingrata pate heffa
dr cortman the toasted chee bang
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis and yuno
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazowski cricket xp
return
day aura very gucci alicia actor bonnie
parks here coming water
joanne garcia 10 note 10 icebergy65
jessica lafond fat boy games deadly
saint and soul rye
slice and dice thank you all so much if
you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patronly discord where we talk
about the latest chapters
anime life and of course thank meme so
check out patreon.com
anime outdoor link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already smashed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space
cowboys
you